[Music]
[Music]
the upcoming game of thrones prequel
series that will air in 2022 house of
the dragon
although based on george rr martin's
targaryen history book fire and blood
will not feature targaryens only but
many other houses and many other
legendary figures from that time period
as well
beside the targaryens we'll have
important starks
lannisters baratheons tarels but also
hightowers
although high towers existed in game of
thrones as well
we had no important high towers in it in
house of the dragon on the other hand
hightowers play the biggest role
alongside targaryens it's soto hightower
the hand of the king
and his daughter alison hightower the
wife of king viserys targaryen with whom
she has children
that basically started the dance of the
dragons targaryen civil war
the key event of the show is also the
key in the history of house targaryen
the dance of the dragons the targaryen
civil war
which divided the entire kingdom and
launched a huge war that was fought from
129 ac to 131 ac
house of the dragon will start with a
build up towards the dance of the
dragons
in early seasons we'll cover the dance
itself seroto hightower was a knight
from house hightower
who served as hand of the king to three
kings
although two of the kings removed him
from office at various times
he was the younger brother of lord
hightower and the uncle of lord dormund
hightower of old town
his children included ellison hightower
the second queen of king wizards the
first targaryen
and serguain hightower second in command
of the gold cloaks
otto is remembered as a warning that
knowledge is not everything
autohightower fights or should i say
serves on the behalf of his grandson
aegon ii targaryens against rhaenyra
targaryen
seroto first served as hand of the king
after the death of prince balon
targaryen
the hand and son of king jahir is the
first targaryen
otto effectively ruled the seven
kingdoms as hand
in the final two years of joharis's
reign while his daughter alice and
hightower nursed the ailing king
otto continued as the hint to jacharys's
grandson and successor on the throne
viserys the first targaryen he became a
bitter rival of the king's brother
prince daemon targaryen who had been
named master of coin
otto convinced the king to remove him
from office
and did so again when viserys named
daemon master of loss
he came to regret this however when
daemon was named commander of the city
watch
as this put two thousand men under
daemon's command
and the prince thrived in this new
office odo feared
daemon would become a second maegor the
cruel if he ever ascended to the iron
throne
sharing his fears with his brother the
lord of the hightower
thus by this time otto wished for
princess rhaenyra to succeed her father
oro's daughter alison became king
viserys's second wife film 106 ac
after the death of queen emma rin in 109
ac
oto was removed as the hand for hounding
viserys to declare alice and sans the
heirs to the iron throne
instead of princess rhaenyra having no
place
at court anymore otto returned to old
town
a queen's party known as the greens the
group of powerful lords
who were friends with queen alicent
remained who supported the rights of
fellows and sons
in 120 ac otto returned as hand
after lord lionel strong died when
viserys died in 129 ac
otto played a crucial role in crowning
his eldest grandson as king aegon the
second in defiance of the last wheel of
viserys the first
which specified rhaenyra as the
successor this defiance precipitated the
civil war known as the dance of the
dragons
the dance of the dragons began with odor
serving as hand of the king
to aegon the second targaryen according
to warwile
otto ordered the confinement of lord
lyman whispering in the black selves
sergbane hightower oda's son was named
as the second
in command of the gold clocks behind sir
luther largent
the blacks were narrowed targaryen's
faction opposing aegon's greens included
the battle-tested prince daemon
targaryen
who in the course of his pre-war
adventures had made many foes
including oda after the death of prince
jaehaerys targaryen at the hands of
daemon's assassins
blood and cheese egg and ordered deaths
of king's landing rat catchers
otto brought a hundred cats to the red
keep
otto reached out to other enemies of the
prince daemon
the kingdom of the three daughters as
allies
they were crucial in breaking the
valyrian blockade in the battle of the
gullet
otto was unsuccessful in gaining an
alliance with cory and martel
the prince of dorne king aegon ii told
his grandfather
thrones are one with swords not quills
spill blood not think aegon ii perceived
otto's diplomacy as slothful at a time
when prince daemon had captured
harrenhal and many houses had declared
for the blacks
this led to oro's replacement as the
hand by sir christon cole
the lord commander of the kingsguard
despite the pleading of queen alice in
hightower
otto's daughter and aegon's mother it
was only after his dismissal
the totoro's diplomatic efforts bore
fruit
just as he had predicted otto was the
first to be beheaded as a traitor by
rhaenyra
after the fall of king's landing in 130
ac
which was not the end of the targaryen
civil war as rhaenyra later loses king's
landing
but it was the end for otto hightower
actor ray seifens will play a role of
otto hightower in house of the dragon
hbo's official description of the
character reads
the hand of the king who loyally and
faithfully serves both his king and his
realm
as the hand sees it the greatest threat
to the realm is the king's brother
daemon
and his position as zeire to the drown
the show will stay true to the books in
this
matter oro's greatest rival in the books
was prince daemon targaryen
and he will also be in the show but most
of the other things however will differ
from the books
not only will there be differences
between the books and the show like it
was with game of thrones
but after reading the book fire and
blood you still don't know how most of
the events really played out
some would think that you could just
read the book fire and blood to know
what will happen in the show based on
that very same book
but that's far from sure why because
fire and blood is not a conventional
novel
it's an imaginary history book and
according to george r martin himself not
very accurate in that
because while firing blood book was
written by george r martin
it was not written from him as facts but
rather to the perspective of the
citadel's archmaester gildane
who gathered all info and as many
different sources as he could
and used it to write a book about the
targaryen history
some info is fake some info is true some
info is semi true
no one will know for a fact what was
happening in real history until the
house of the dragon airs in 2022
the show unlike the book will contain
truth it will depict what actually
happened
not the changed history fake or semi
true
not what might or might not have
happened fire and blood is a complete
history of house targaryen written by
george rr martin from the perspective of
archmaester gildane
who wrote it many decades after the
events took place
sure most of the main events such as
battles and deaths probably did happen
but as gildane says it in the books the
full truth about what happened behind
closed doors in the privacy of
stairwells council rooms
and bed chambers he does not fully know
and he turns to many different sources
which usually differ from one another he
looks into the course of chronicles
laid down by grand maester runsider and
his successors and many court
documents as well gildane looks into
accounts written
decades later by children and
grandchildren of those
caught up in the events of these times
while they are undoubtedly of use
so much time has passed between the
event and the recording
that many confusions and contradictions
have inevitably crept in
unfortunately this is also true for
gildan's two accounts by first hand
observers
that have come down to him septoneustes
who served in the royals sept in the red
keep
during much of this time and spent much
time as a confident
and confessor to king viserys and his
queens
his account is biased favoring aegon
over rhaenyra
the second account is based upon a
verbal account of the court full
mushroom
who was present at court for all of them
for king viserys princess
and queen rhaenyra and both king aegons
the second and the third during his
reign
king balor the first targaryen had
mushroom's book burned on account of its
scandalous content
there are several main sources for
historical information on the dance of
the dragons
which are frequently at odds with each
other gildan also used this source
written by grand maestro wild
who had served king aegon the second
targaryen on his council
and was arrested by the forces of queen
rhaenyra targaryen
when she took the city orwell wrote his
account while locked away in the black
cells
uncertain about whether or not he would
survive the war
he attempted to paint himself in the
best light possible
grain maester monkens the dance of the
dragons said true telling was based on
orwell's account using all these sources
which often differ from one another
archmaester gildan wrote his work fire
and blood
his work about the history of house
targaryen this format brings up martin's
major thematic point about the
uncertainty of memory
and history being written by winners
neither side
truly won the war and decades after the
war both sides wrote their own biased
history books
trying to put their actions in a better
light thus history is written by the
green's depicted ii
in good light and rhaenyra in a bad
light
on the other hand histories written by
the blacks do the opposite
we'll know exactly what happened in this
time period when the show airs
and that's why you cannot just read the
book fire and blood and think you would
know what actually happened or what will
happen on the show
books are written by archmaester decades
and decades after the events took place
using many sources that in most cases
are very different from each other and
most of them are biased as well
what we can tell you for a fact is that
house of the dragon starts filming in
around 3 weeks
and will air in 2022 on hbo we can also
tell you that otto hightower will play a
huge role
he is the grandfather of fagon ii and he
alongside his daughter queen ellison
starred targaryen civil war the war
began
when king viserys the first died started
by the greens
otto and ellis and hightower among
others by disobeying king viserys's
orders of crowning rhaenyra
and instead crowning aegon as the new
king of westeros
the same day that viserys the first died
aegon the second's followers the green
stage daku
and he was soon crowned in king's
landing rhaenyra as the princess of
dragonstone had her power base on
dragonstone island where she responded
by being crowned queen by daemon and
declaring a gonna traitor
does the targaryen civil war begin thank
you so much for watching if you enjoyed
this video please give it a big thumbs
up and i hope to see you in the next one
peace